do you think I can heal my broken neck
with meditation when when doctors say
it's not gonna connect do you think I
can manifest that connection happening
with that boom that broke up yes
meditation is about practicing when we
learn how to focus our attention when we
learn some techniques to use our brain
better then we're empowered we are able
to really become everything we are meant
to become mr. John Assaraf there is hey
there my friend how are you good how are
you amazing
if you guys know John Assaraf author of
the awesome book inner thighs just like
you got to exercise your body inner
thighs is for the internal the mindset
the brainwaves overcoming fears building
the habits that matter John I was I was
at your place basically a year ago yeah
he's got this awesome office and I sat
down we did this awesome interview and
we talked about me becoming famous and
my resistance to doing it and you give
me some fantastic advice and I just
wanted to kind of follow up the start to
say that since then I went on and and
spoke in front of thousands of people
shared the stage with Brendon Burchard
and Dean grad coz and a whole bunch of
amazing people and took a YouTube
channel of 300 million views and a lot
of you know good voices in my head
constantly coat the ear saying that
message can open open so I appreciate
you
I appreciate you too as well my friend I
always hope when today to talk about
meditation mm-hmm I know is this
something that you're really big on and
and I've struggled to unlock properly I
know you've got your your Harlow's thing
cuz that's what happened at your policy
the five day program
Halas think is a tool it's just a
meditative tool that basically in trains
your brain there's a lot of different
tools that you can use there's a lot of
different types of meditations and and
so some people prefer meditating without
the aid of a tool some people prefer to
use a tool so there's a variety of
different tools that people could use we
talk about you know which ones they are
which ones work for different people or
wine so let's start with what is your
daily meditation practice okay so for
example it's eight o'clock in the
morning here in San Diego right now
about two hours ago when I woke up the
first thing that I do after I pee is I
go sit on my sofa looking at the ocean
and this morning for example I was just
doing a very quiet breathing meditation
listening to sound bowls so I bought
some audios on the internet somewhere
somebody had some really good sound
bowls where you know they're there
they're hitting the sound bowls or
rotating a little piece of wood around
the sound bowl and I just focus on
releasing any of my own thoughts I focus
on concentrating and and listening just
to the waves that the sound bowls create
so in doing that what actually is
happening is I'm learning that I could
be still I'm learning that I could be
aware of my thoughts but then let them
go and I come back to focus on a sound
wave in this particular meditation and
then what happens is over a period of
practice you realize that you're
basically your body disappears you're no
longer in this physical thing you're no
longer having these waves of thought
after thought after thought after
thought after thought after idea
positive negative and everything in
between
and in that space of recognizing that
I'm not my physical body I have a
physical body I'm not my thoughts I have
thoughts I'm not my emotions I have them
when you start to train yourself to use
your brain better more efficiently more
productively you realize that a I am one
with this you know incredible universe
so what's the big deal about that well
the big deal is that if I am one with
this universe with this energy with
everyone and everything and that's where
everything
percolates from is it possible that all
my answers are right here right now
anyway and the answer is yeah and so
meditation is about practicing and we
know that we have different brain waves
so right now as people are watching or
listening you know they're in this beta
brainwave frequency where their brain is
oscillating at a certain frequency
there's 50 different brain waves going
on at any given time
but what happens is when I move into
from beta 2 alpha 2 theta Delta or gamma
I'm actually accessing and activating
different parts of my brain which now
gives me this deeper greater sense of
awareness of a much bigger you know
onion that I'm used to seeing so I'm
living on a layer of an onion and what
if I could see like ten layers up and
ten layers down all of a says like wow
look at Who I am what I am who you are
what you are and in that realization in
that awareness I can now start to have
different choice choices made and so
meditation is a practice of awareness
it's a practice of going internal
instead of external which is where most
people live their lives every day so
what I've done it I like that this
different kinds of meditation and in the
focused part I'm super super easy for me
to not get distracted and just stay
focused hurt for an hour whatever but
where I where I struggle with is the
people who say that when they sit down
and they meditate for an hour it only
feels like five minutes has gone by
who's like an altered state of
consciousness as opposed to just
mindfulness and being present have you
ever read a book or watched a movie and
all of a sudden you look up and you
realize thirty forty minutes has gone by
yeah when every time I talk to you I
feel like holy cow we only talk for we
talk for half an hour don't think it was
only two minutes but that's a meditative
state so right we can have meditative
States while we're watching a movie we
could have meditative trance like state
while we're reading a book we can have a
meditative state but we're looking to
each other's
and we're so in love that we just lose
ourselves and oh my god where did the
time go it's been five or six hours that
you know we've been transfixed on each
other we can have a meditative state
sitting quietly not even breathing that
our skin is breathing so all of these
meditative States mindfulness states are
geared towards giving us a much greater
understanding and awareness of
connectedness of source that we all
emanate from and the question is like
why would you want to do that and the
answer is in the world that we live in
right now it is non-stop stimuli
non-stop distraction texts emails
Instagram Facebook Twitter Pinterest
YouTube all of the things people like
you and me looking to have our audiences
come learn with us that we can teach and
share you know everybody's being
distracted well what we do know is you
know I keep this magnifying glass right
here on my desk and this is to remind me
that you know the Sun is you know a ball
of nuclear fusion and energy and it
heats up a general area and you can get
a nice little ten if you stay in the Sun
long enough well if I take a magnifying
glass I could take that same Sun and I
could take you know this sheet of paper
right and if I can get the magnifying
glass and the sheet of paper lined up I
could burn this piece of paper by
focusing the energy well I could take
that same energy of the Sun but I can
magnify through a magnifying glass but
now if I can focus it to a single photon
that's known as a laser I can cut
through steel well is it possible that
yours in my brain the most powerful
electromagnetic switching station or
tool in the universe that's taking a
light that's coming in through our eyes
sound that's coming in through our ears
is it possible that we can train
ourselves to focus so intently on our
vision
on our goal on releasing what doesn't
serve us on starting what will help us
achieve our goals better is it possible
that meditation and/or mindfulness
allows us to focus our brain's energy on
a vision and goal and outcome so
intently that we are resonating and
oscillating a hundred trillion cells of
our body because of our focus of our
brain and we are in alignment and
resonance or in harmony with what it is
that we want to achieve do be or have
and the answer is yes because everything
in the universe is made up of energy
including my body and cleaning you know
this magnifying glass including my pen
so the very art of learning how to use
my brain the greatest organism in the
known universe it's an organism that we
can manipulate and use better now allows
me know differently then you know I can
take a radio or my cell phone right I
can turn the dial and tune into a
different station 95.1 is rock-and-roll
95.5 is classical music ninety-five
point eight is punk rock if we learn or
when we learn to use our brain better
more efficiently more precisely to tune
into what it is that we want is it
possible that that is using the law of
attraction or residence or harmony the
way we're supposed to be using it so
that we can achieve more of the goals
and dreams we have but in a diffused
fractured state okay we're not able to
use our brains as well so meditation
gives you the ability to focus your
intention and attention on the outcomes
that you want versus what you don't want
there's a long-winded answer when you
sit down to meditate do you come with an
intention then each time mmm no I when
once I sit down then I ask my intuition
hey what is it that you want to be doing
today what is it that you need today
we all have this intuition which is
different than our instinct but this
intuition right it's what we know before
we think and so when I sit down and say
okay hey what's what's the intention for
today
and sometimes the intention is to just
let go and see what happens sometimes
the intention is I'm searching for you
know for an answer
sometimes the intention is well today
focus you know today let go today just
breathe so I just listen I just it's
just it's it's the the art and the
subtle signs of paying attention and I
have a philosophy that every moment
every precious nanosecond and moment is
perfect and so when I connect to the
perfection of that moment there's really
nothing to do it's to be aware and to
allow to surrender but not to give up
surrender but to understand that you
know as you know we are talking right
now the oceans don't need any
instruction what to do the the planets
that are moving in their elliptical
orbits around the Sun don't need yours
or my intervention the universe the
Milky Way galaxy that's you know flowing
through the universe at a million 1/2
miles per hour doesn't need yours in my
instruction so that means that every
moment is perfect so I want to connect
to the perfection of every single moment
be aware of that every single moment and
realize that many things are not to my
taste many things I don't understand but
that doesn't mean that the moment isn't
perfect and so then can I direct a
little bit of this you know physical
body can I direct my mind can I manage
my emotions well enough to make sure
that what I do has purpose what I do has
meaning what I do brings value what I do
brings me joy what I do brings me
happiness and the answer is of course
and that's where you know I share a lot
you know in my book inner size is
awareness is what gives you choice
and it's choice that gives you freedom
and so in choice we're no longer victims
in choice okay we can become victorious
and everybody who's watching wants to
become victorious on their lives right
and so what if all we had to do is pay
attention
remember the perfection that you are
remember the genius that you are
remember that you can achieve whatever
it is you choose to achieve now let's
learn the art of focus let's linearity
of concentration let's learn the art of
letting go and surrendering
you know and priscilla's right all is
perfect in this precious moment or
present moment okay can you share
something that maybe this week came to
you in a meditation that you weren't
even thinking about otherwise and you
acted on I just got back from skiing in
in Utah and one of the one of my
passions is to is to do some skiing
where I hiked up and ski down these
steeper terrain which is I've been
petrified of doing because I've been
hurt once before doing that and so this
this ski run that we were just at alter
which for the first time I was hiking up
I was panting like a dog going up you
know for 11,000 feet elevation and at
the top of the hill I just said okay let
me enter into a meditative state I'm 58
years old I've skied for you know 35
years every moment of skiing the the
stuff I've done well the stuff that you
know that I've learned through some of
the failures of skiing I'm bringing to
this moment right now so I did a little
meditation at the top of the ski hill I
just closed my eyes and I just did some
breathing exercise just to connect you
know to to myself my emotions the
present moment remembering that every
moment is perfect that I'm skilled
enough to be able to do this and I went
I just went and I trusted that this
moment was perfect or I wouldn't be
there so this was my opportunity to take
the lessons and to practice in this
moment and I had one of the best skier
of my life in a meditative state and it
happened so fast
thank God my friends were down the hill
videotaping where I can actually see it
and I was like oh my god that's like one
of my best ski runs ever and the reason
for that is is I went into this calm
relaxed responsive state versus a
fearful reactive state by going into a
meditative awareness mindfulness state
of the moment and and so that was a
perfect opportunity for me to go wow you
know it wasn't just that moment but it
was the fifty you know or thirty five
years of skiing you know that came to
that moment and and so that's a
meditative state where I was one with
the mountain with everything else and it
may sound esoteric all may sound crazy
but you know all we have which everybody
talks about is this this moment this
this precious second right now so the
more I could be here right now the more
on living you know the life that I want
to live I don't want this isn't too much
about the future too much about the past
that can use those as something to you
know hope for in the future is a guiding
posts from the past but right now is the
moment that every one of us has loved it
now I broke my neck in two spots last
year on my tour and remember them healed
and the other part there's actually a
piece of my neck that broke off that's
still there that they don't want to
operate on do you think there's a
station I love it well that's what I
want to show you there's Einstein which
represents our left prefrontal cortex
the the the smart genius part of our
brain that has imagination that can come
up with all the ideas of what about this
what about this I can have ii have this
what most people don't understand is we
also have right a frankenstein part of
our brain the inner critic you know it
says but you're not good enough you're
not smart enough what if you fail what
if you're embarrassed what if you're
ashamed so we have this you know that's
why I have them there's Einstein and
there's Frankenstein just to remind me
and to remind my students
that both exist within us and our goal
is to understand that you know the way
our brain works is there's always a
protective side of our brain so
Frankenstein's always wanting what if
you fail
what do you succeed to fail what if you
disappoint yourself an Einstein is going
don't worry about it imagine the future
and so there's this constant battle in
our brains you know going on an our goal
and meditation is one of the best ways
to recognize that both exist and both
are right your Frankenstein part of your
brain is there to protect you your
Einstein brain is is ready to help you
achieve your goals and dreams and the
keys to remember you're not your brain
you're not the Einstein part you're not
the Frankenstein part there's another
side of you that is much greater than
all of it and that's what meditation
helps you remember that I have a brain I
have the Einstein the Frankenstein and
the ugly side of myself and the nasty
side of myself in the beautiful side of
myself in the loving side of myself and
the critical side of myself all of that
is a part of who everyone of us is and
when I start to realize that and I say
okay now I can choose do I focus on you
know Einstein and create what I want or
do I focus on Frankenstein and destruct
which one do I want so anyway a little
bit of fun I like it so so do you think
I can heal my broken neck with
meditation when when doctors say it's
not gonna connect do you think I can
manifest that connection happening with
that bone that broke up yes so why do I
say that
well we have a hundred trillion cells in
our body I've had neck injuries shoulder
injuries meniscus injuries I've had
ankle injuries I've had injuries because
I've always been pretty athletic if you
think about what is happening every time
I breathe in I'm breathing in hydrogen
oxygen nitrogen carbon plus a whole
bunch of other elements from the air
what do you think your bones and tissues
and muscles are made of I'm eating you
know it's a I'm eating a protein whether
it's toe
or a piece of chicken right I'm eating
protein that is making muscle I'm eating
fat I'm drinking water we are made up of
hydrogen oxygen nitrogen carbon mostly
and so every 7 years we're making a
whole new body our eyeballs are
different our skeleton is different our
brain is not the same cells that were in
our brain seven years ago our lungs
liver heart tissues nothing is the same
and so if I am visualizing if I am
meditating if I am seeing a new healed
bone if I'm seeing a new healed part of
my being is it possible that I can
direct some of what's happening in my
body and the answer is of course I can
there are so many people that have
healed okay from traumatic brain
injuries from back injuries from from
tears and all that stuff and so I
absolutely believe that we can heal so
that is that is my opinion and we are
just starting to scratch the proverbial
surface of what our potential really is
and starts with our brain so what should
my next step be I've got this piece of
bone folder under my neck I want to
connect it look at my daily practice be
well the question you know that I would
be asking number one is is is connecting
it what you want to be doing right is it
possible to release it and then regrow
some bone deliberately right so so I
would be looking at first I would be
doing a whole bunch of research of who
has actually done what I want to do
right though is there one person on
earth that has recovered from the type
of trauma that I have so I would look at
the science first and maybe the
metaphysics behind it I would be
visualizing every single day my next
field so I'll give you an example maybe
I can put this into perspective for some
some of you when I was 22 years old I
was diagnosed with severe ulcerative
colitis right I think I've and you and I
talked about this before
yeah and severe all serrated Collider
is when your colon is inflamed it does
this but I had ulcers in my coal and it
was bleeding and I had zero bowel
control movement I if I had to go to the
bathroom he's like run and sometimes I
would just shift right in my pants it
doesn't make a difference who was around
where I was in the restaurant in bed
having sex in my cart made no difference
if I had to go it was like done and I
watched the TV show on
psychoneuroimmunology the mind-body
connection and at the time I was 22
years old trying to work trying to make
make money and I want to hear what was
causing my ulcerative colitis cuz the
ulcerative colitis was an effect right
so then what was causing it and what I
realized was causing it was a lot of
stress the wrong foods too much alcohol
no exercise etc so I said okay well how
could I heal myself and at the time I
was taking 25 pills a day I was doing
enemas in the morning enemas at night
and going to the hospital once a month
for them to stick a tube in my rectum to
see what was happening in my colon not
fun at 22 years old it's like what the
front door right and so I said okay let
me see if I could really heal myself and
so I wrote an affirmation I wish I had
it here does that reach it says my body
in all its organs were created by the
infinite intelligence in my subconscious
mind it created all my bones tissues
muscles liver lungs heart and everything
else within me it knows how to heal me I
am now perfectly healthy that's a short
version of that and every day in
addition to eating well exercising
sleeping well I would read this
affirmation I would close my eyes I
would see my colon heal I would see my
colon sick I'd see my colon heal I'd see
my colon six sick my colon healed that
that's called mental contrasting in the
world of neuroscience and so I could see
this over and over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over in my brain I would read it I
would feel it I would see it five weeks
of doing this after two-and-a-half years
of being sick
all of my symptoms went away a hundred
percent when I went in to see my
doctor's name was dr. Wu he said to me
you had a spontaneous remission I said
it's not a spontaneous remission it was
a deliberate remission that was 36 years
ago all right and the doctor says
whatever you're doing you know keep
doing it but I want you to still take
the pills I was taking 25 pills a day I
said to him I said doctor who you don't
understand do you
I said I fixed the cause you still want
to treat the symptom right and so I've
shown people how to get off of colitis
Crohn's disease diverticulitis our body
is consistently re manifesting itself
based on our thoughts emotions feelings
sensations and behaviors so what is
everyone watching what if I could be in
a vibration mentally heartwise right
emotionally and got wise so heart brain
heart and gut what if I can create
alignment so that I'm in a state of
health so my body is regenerating
healthy cells
my body's regenerating you know you're
activating energy from my mitochondria
what if I could be in this alignment
with the flow of health versus a flow of
dis so for you you know what happens
with most people's they're focusing on
their disease or their pain instead of
channeling their attention of energy in
focusing on health and well-being so the
more you say you know my neck is broken
my neck is broken I've got a little
thing on my necks it's painful my neck
the doctor said I can't this is
impossible the more you keep reinforcing
the cellular activity that reinforces
that so there's the difference between
between sticking your head in the stand
and pretending that the symptom isn't
there and what you focus on so the
symptom is there but the symptom okay is
there because of something that happened
the past if I keep recreating what
happened in the past
I just keep recreating at the cellular
structure the continuity of that we're
saying yes what I have right now is
because of the past I accept that and
now I'm focusing on being a hundred
percent healthy big big difference now
we're not lying to ourselves because I
don't believe we should do right and by
the way somebody somebody asked in here
and by the way if you're if you're all
enjoying this hit the like you're the
love button for me and Evan so we know
you're you're enjoying this so I want to
share one one critical piece here
somebody asked earlier you know you know
can you do this her drug addiction a lot
of people don't know this but I used to
be addicted to alcohol I haven't had a
drink in over 10 years and I haven't had
alcohol in 11 and 1/2 out of 13 years
when I was going through a really
challenging time in my life through a
business partnership breaker with one of
my best friends I would drink a bottle
of wine a night and I realized oh my god
I am hiding my emotions I'm getting
addicted to alcohol as a way to deal
with these emotions right I want to
suppress and I used the exact same
process to stop drinking I've used the
exact same process to stop eating sugar
because I was addicted to sugar I use
the exact same process most of you don't
know this I wish I had a picture but I
was 243 pounds 10 years ago I'm a
hundred and ninety-five pounds today
I've lost 43 pounds of fat I've kept it
off for 10 years why because I'm
focusing on the inner game the power
within you and me is so great that when
we learn how to focus our attention when
we learned some techniques to use our
brain better then we're empowered we are
able to really become everything we are
meant to become which is what every one
of us wants we want to know you know am
i ok you know do you love me do I do I
love myself how do I have purpose and
meaning and that's really what we all
want we want this connection but we also
want to know that our lives matter and
that we're gonna be ok knock integrity
you're gonna be ok maybe you just need
to tweak a little bit of what you're
doing I love it if you guys might see
that
go to John's Instagram John Assaraf he
posted it you might to go back a little
bit but it's an awesome picture John
asked up in the house the book is inner
sighs I got I got my signed copy here
but you guys need to go up and pick this
book young people want to find out more
about you for the YouTube audience where
do you want them to go listen with your
help we're finally recalibrating our
YouTube channel so they can see some of
my videos on YouTube I'm here on
Instagram as well so I've got an
Instagram channel I'm on there every day
also I'm gonna start doing videos now
that I see what you're doing to you know
to master this medium you're just you
know so phenomenal with what you do so
thank you for leading the pack for for
us who you know want to help other
people in the world so Instagram YouTube
I do a little training every Tuesday
morning on Facebook on my fan page as
well so amazing John thank you as always
I took a whole bunch of notes I'm glad
to have it recording so it can go back
because I always miss stuff and I get so
much your life from talking you
appreciate you mine thank you appreciate
you too my friend bye everyone
have an awesome thank you if you want to
see the one on one I did with John
Astaroth in his office in California
where he helped me get over my fear of
becoming famous check out the video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there our job is to figure out like why
am I